which for the record is not flat
this of course cylindrical that's why we
can both see the curve of the horizon
and fall off the edge of the planet it's
just science everyone that's a science
fact specifically we want to talk about
the challenges facing the environment
often when this subject comes up on TV
the solution is presented as a bunch of
fun recycling ideas like this so we're
having an Earth Day birthday party so
check this one out your old garden hoses
do you love these little baskets
that's cute so easy to make and no
special tools it's just a hose and zip
ties if that's oh my gosh it's a little
weird to see a grown adult be that
excited by some garden hoses tied
together with zip ties although I do
actually have to admit it's pretty
awesome garden hose like around
my living room for ages I have no idea
what to do with it now it's a basket I
use for all those picnics I attend I
love it and I wish to be buried with my
hose basket unfortunately though fun
crafty tips like those clearly aren't
doing enough to save our planet these
days were inundated with new terrifying
headlines on a regular basis including a
landmark report from the United Nations
panel on climate change just last fall
that contained some devastating
conclusions the scientists found that if
greenhouse gas emissions continue at the
current rate we could start seeing
worsening food shortages at wildfires
and a mass die-off of coral reefs as
soon as 2040 2040
that's just 21 years from now by that
point fin wolfhard will only be 37
ariana grande will only be 46 and Lou
Dobbs will only have been dead for 30
years
so have any hope of avoiding those
consequences the report found that
unprecedented efforts are going to be
required and to that end there's one
recent proposal that gets discussed a
lot here are a few of the times that it
was mentioned just in the past week she
backs the green New Deal the green New
Deal makes no sense how do you achieve
the green New Deal factor in the new
Green Deal green New Deal the green New
Deal agree New Deal green New Deal
through the green new deal the green New
Deal
if you knew nothing else about the green
New Deal you now know that everyone's
talking about it and it was booed at a
trump rally therefore it is a famous and
B probably good and and again all those
clips were from this week which is
actually pretty amazing considering the
fact that the Senate voted the green New
Deal down six weeks ago and think about
that how often do we talk about
legislation after Congress votes it down
how often do we talk about legislation
before Congress votes it down we talk
about legislation about as much as we
talked about suits before we knew who
Meagan Locker was we weren't talking
about suits even go to the water cooler
and say hey Fred you catch suits the
other night that Harvey Specter has
portrayed by Gabriel Marx sure is a
piece of work a on suits on the TV
program suits that's captured my
imagination and that the green new deal
has been famously polarizing on one hand
all these senators running for president
co-sponsored it on the other hand
Republicans have been foaming at the
mouth to criticize it for all the crazy
provisions that they insist it contains
their so-called green New Deal proposes
the elimination of air travel
eliminating cars airplanes flatulent
cows and for good measure tearing down
all of our buildings you can't stop cows
from flatulating you got to eliminate
cows which means they're coming after
our hamburgers congressmen they want to
take away your hamburgers this is what
stalin dreamt about but never at
what are you talking about that's not
Stalin's dream that is the hamburglar's
dream you confusing stalling with the
hamburger what you're actually
understandable once said the state is an
instrument in the hands of the work
ruling class while the other said robble
robble similar vibes subtle differences
so given that the green New Deal is
still very much on people's minds we
thought it might be worth taking a look
at it tonight to see what it is what it
isn't and most importantly where we
should maybe go from here and the first
thing to understand is that the green
New Deal doesn't even mention the word
cows or airplanes in fact well it's
sometimes discussed like it's filled
with specific programs to fight climate
change it isn't it is a non-binding
resolution that very briefly sets out
some extremely aggressive goals
including achieving Net Zero greenhouse
gas emissions meeting a hundred percent
of the country's power demand through
clean renewable and zero emission energy
sources and creating millions of good
high wage jobs in the United States the
whole great New Deal is just 14 pages
long that is seven pages shorter than
the menu for the Cheesecake Factory and
then you which by the way should have
exactly one item on it pie that's right
I said it
pie is the only good dessert it's got
fruit it's got bread it's got goo it is
a true triple threat but it's important
to note the green New Deal contains no
detailed specifics on how it will
achieve any of its goals which sounds
like a criticism but it is really not
the plans backers led by Alexandria
Castillo Cortez said repeatedly right
from the outset that the green New Deal
was merely meant to kick-start a
conversation set some aggressive targets
so that we could then figure out how to
hit them our first step is to define the
problem and define the scope of the
solution and so we're here to say that
small incremental policy solutions are
not enough right at a certain point your
problems get so big do you have no
choice but to do something drastic
sometimes you're just getting too deep
sometimes you make a young man's mistake
like falling in love with the beautiful
wife of a mafioso he puts a price on
your head she's swear she'll leave him
for you but you can't do that you can't
make her live the life of a fugitive so
you faked your own death in a falafel
cart collision and sail to America to
start things fresh you tell everyone
there that you were a comedian in
England and despite your ridiculous
cartoon accent and no one in England
having ever heard of you no one really
questions it this kind of a life I
suppose
eking out a living reading off stats and
jokes once a week on premium cable but
not a night goes by that you don't dream
of the white Sardinian sands and the
soft lips of isabella just example it's
just the example off the top of my head
so the green New Deal was meant to be a
conversation starter but unless you like
bad faith conversations about farting
cows that conversation has not gone well
so far and much of that was clearly
inevitable there were people who were
never going to support this plan but
there were also some self-inflicted
wounds the reason you hear Hamburg has
come up so much is that a o'seas office
mistakenly sent an early draft of an FAQ
to reporters containing language like we
set a goal to get to net zero rather
than zero emissions in ten years because
we aren't sure that we'll be able to
fully get rid of farting cows and
airplanes that fast which is clearly
supposed to be a joke but it wasn't a
great time to attempt one and even aoc
admits the rollout of the green New Deal
was the biggest mistake she's made in
Congress and she is right about that
because it gave an opening for these
idiots to pretend the green New Deal was
all about hamburger stealing when it is
not although for the record there are
real environmental issues surrounding
cattle farming among them that cows do
emit a lot of methane which is a
greenhouse gas although even there
there's a slight misconception about
which end of the cow is most responsible
first I want to correct a misnomer that
cows don't fart they actually belch
that's true
that's true most cow methane comes from
them belching not farting and if you
only remember one fact from tonight's
show please
do not let it be that one please just
forget that now
but while the rollout of this
conversation has been bumpy it is great
that the green New Deal has started one
so let's talk about what a plan to
combat climate change could look like
and the first thing to understand here
is no one solution is going to be nearly
enough here we need to tackle this from
multiple angles and there are lots of
ideas out there including building a
better power grid improving battery
storage developing low carbon jet fuel
electrifying industrial processes
building cities more densely facing our
HFCS developing lab-grown meat building
better nuclear plants upgrading our
thermostats increasing mass transit
ridership and scaling up carbon capture
technology and I could talk about all of
those but it would take me all night and
I know that you want to watch the rerun
of Game of Thrones so that you can see
what garbage from craft services they've
hidden as an easter egg this week it's
right there it's right there though
sprinkle can those sprinkles aren't
supposed to be there they don't have
that type of Pringles in Westeros that's
ridiculous
so so instead of discussing all of those
let's instead focus on one policy that
you're likely to hear about as this
conversation continues and that's carbon
pricing the current situation with
carbon is critical carbon emissions are
by far the largest source of greenhouse
gases yet right now is basically free to
pollute the air with carbon dioxide
which is a little bit weird when you
think about it because we've universally
agreed that polluting is bad and yet
it's free to do it when you litter you
pay a fine when you drive above the
speed limit you pay a fine when you
steal 400 hamsters from Petsmart tie
them to a sled and race through the
streets on a hamster sleigh you pay a
fine is that fine worth it yes of course
it is
but you do pay it now carbon pricing is
a little complicated so to break down
the logic behind it I've enlisted the
help of a guy who's made a career out of
explaining complex ideas with fun visual
stunts hi John
Bill Nye the Science Guy here I'm going
to explain the complicated logic behind
carbon pricing but first safety glasses
on when something costs more people buy
less of it safety glasses off that's it
honestly I was expecting something a bit
more fun and visual of that bill could
you maybe explain the long-term impact
of carbon pricing but but with a cool
stunt you know to jazz up what you're
saying gone okay safety glasses on when
we release carbon say by burning coal or
driving an SUV all of us pay for that in
the form of things like fires floods and
crop failures putting a fee on carbon
creates incentives to emit less carbon
and more importantly it also
incentivizes the development of low
carbon technology which is huge because
that's vital to reducing emissions
globally and because for some reason
John you're a 42 year old man who needs
his attention sustained with tricks
here's some Mentos and a popular
diet cook
[Applause]
happy now busy I love it I love it Bella
love it I love it I love it but but he
is point about incentivizing new
technology is really important
especially because our current
low-carbon technology strategies
essentially hope that this guy stops
calling people pedophiles long enough to
invent an affordable electric car and
right now the pedophile to car balance
is way off so in theory putting a price
on carbon makes complete sense and you
should know that there is absolutely
nothing extreme about this idea
economists across the political spectrum
supported and more than 40 governments
worldwide have done it including the UK
where carbon pricing has contributed to
co2 emissions falling to their lowest
level since 1890 that's right the lowest
level since before Mary Poppins danced
with Chimney Sweeps and introduced the
banks children to cocaine yes okay
you thought the spoonful of sugar was
actually sugar come on how do you
explain the dancing penguins she gave
those children cocaine and she changed
their lives forever
now there are different ways there are
different ways to put a price on carbon
one is cap-and-trade where you cap the
total amount of emissions the companies
allowed to release and you let them
trade emissions permits among themselves
or there's the more straightforward
carbon tax was just as a surcharge to
activities that emit carbon the problem
there is mostly the word tax which has
become a dirty word in politics just
look what happened in Canada which
rolled out a new carbon tax that went
into effect just last month although it
was not easy for them to do that Justin
Trudeau desperately tried not to use the
word tax instead calling it a price on
pollution and when he slipped up once
just look how people reacted what we
were also guaranteeing is that this tax
this pricing
listen to the level of excitement over
that verbal slip up if you're a
politician you just can't say the word
tax in the same way that if you're an
actor you can't say the word Macbeth and
if you're president in the United States
you can't say the word origins
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation it's funny because his
brain is turning into pudding
anyway anyway the point is Trudeau
simply say the word tax was described as
Trudeau trips on his own words so on
what level you can kind of understand
his reluctance to use that term because
it exposed him to fear-mongering
about what his policy would mean for
regular people which sometimes took the
form of catchy slam poetry from his
political opponents we can't afford this
onerous feed 11 cents more for a litre
of fuel taxing me in my kids school
farms and families will feel the pinch
when the carbon tax man pulls the Cinch
tax the tractor combine plow tax the
chicken egg and cow carbon tax man
enough Sanath don't can't tax Canadians
at all their stop fire look I don't care
where you stand on this issue no one
wants to hear a rhyme about carbon taxes
from anybody let alone some guy who
looks like he got his entire wardrobe at
Express John Oliver not a fan but but he
is here speaking to a real concern there
ha
Howard typical now you see it now
Oh sings
how do you put a price on carbon and
make things more expensive without
harming the people who can least afford
them what Canada is doing to address
this is actually pretty simple very
basically they're taking the money they
collect and giving it back to their
citizens they're doing this by pooling
the money gathered by increased fees on
things like gas and heat dividing it up
and sending it back to taxpayers as a
rebate in fact they've designed it so
that the rebates in Canada are
anticipated to exceed the increased
costs for about 70 percent of households
with Lois lowest income households
seeing the most benefits from the policy
which is great but even with that being
true the fight over a carbon tax was and
still is very difficult in Canada it's
no wonder that some politicians in this
country are wary of even attempting a
debate about carbon pricing in fact the
last national attempt that got any real
traction here was ten years ago when
Congress tried passing a cap-and-trade
bill and the debate around it got so
toxic West Virginia Democrat Joe Manchin
was comfortable expressing his
displeasure like this I'm Joe Manchin I
approve this ad because I'll always
defend West Virginia hi Sudeep EA and
I'll take dead aim at the cap-and-trade
bill because it's bad for West Virginia
now that may seem idiotic to you because
it is but but but in fairness that is
actually the only way to stop a bill
from becoming a law that bill had a
knife you all sort you all saw it it
reads for its pockets look look look I I
know that this can all seem hopeless
especially under the current
administration but there are actually
some small signs that the tide may be
turning here the very fact that we're
still talking about the green New Deal
is really encouraging plus the
percentage of conservative Republicans
who say they are very or somewhat
worried by global warming has more than
doubled in the last five years even
Mitch McConnell
finally acknowledged the role of humans
in climate change from the first time a
few weeks ago and yes that is a bit like
him giving a speech titled Alf is
actually just a big puppet I mean yeah
Mitch
we all know that Mitch it's
embarrassing it's taken you this long to
accept it but better late than never I
guess
however bumpy its rollout was to its
eternal credits the green New Deal has
succeeded in getting people talking but
that won't mean anything unless that
talk now turns to actions and putting a
price on carbon could potentially be one
of them although let me reiterate it
will not be enough on its own by a long
shot we're gonna need a lot of different
policies working in tandem and we have
to take action right now but you don't
have to just take that from me instead
I'm happy to say that Bill Nye has
actually agreed to help drive the
urgency home at this point by actually
doing one of his enjoyable light-hearted
demonstrations so bill please please do
you have a fun experiment for us here
I've got an experiment for you safety
glasses on by the end of this century
for missions keep rising the average
temperature on earth could go up another
four to eight degrees what I'm saying is
the planets on fire there are a
lot of things we could do to put it out
are any of them free no of course not
nothing's free you idiots grow the
up
you're not children anymore I didn't
mind explaining photosynthesis to you
when you were 12 but you're adults now
and this is an actual crisis got it
safety glasses off
I think we've all broken Bill Nye and I
for one am absolutely on board with his
new gritty reboot
[Applause]